since august of 2018 these two show
girls at main street in las vegas
boulevard have welcomed visitors to the
great downtown las vegas they've become
a popular spot for photos and selfies
but if you've driven by this area
recently you may have noticed something
conspicuously missing
uh the showgirls you know they're out
traveling the world they needed a
vacation and to get on a plane have a
rest
actually with the incredible growth of
downtown in this area mayor carolyn
goodman thought it's a perfect time for
the ladies to grow the reality is
they're going to be relocated one day
soon down at the 3rd street down on 3rd
street because i felt they were way too
small
as everything happened down there by the
strat by our beautiful arches
i said to our staff my goodness they
shrank so they are being reborn as two
new showgirls 50 feet tall but it's not
like you can just feed the original
showgirls some steroids being reborn as
50 feet show girls well that's quite a
feat
they were due for a rehab and in order
to rehab them we have to take them out
and bring them back to the vendor's
factory to get rehab as that rehab
project was identified in conversations
with the mayor we saw it as an
opportunity to revisit the showgirls
gateway and what that revisit came about
was let's do an upgrade to the showgirls
gateway at maine and las vegas boulevard
in conjunction with a new gateway
opportunity at 4th street and las vegas
boulevard as you're entering into the
arts district specifically for the deuce
bus
and so we saw an opportunity to marry
the two projects together and what
resulting what's resulting in is a pair
of 50-foot showgirls at las vegas
boulevard in maine and 25-foot showgirls
at the entrance to the arts district off
off of fourth and boulevard so not to
worry the original showgirls are not
gone they're just relocating to another
area to make way for larger versions
same glitz and glamour just more of it